- This video is sponsored by SelfDecode.
(upbeat music)
What's up, guys?
Helen here with a
confession: I'm an Aquarius,
meaning I'm idealistic
and chronically late.
You're probably thinking,
"Why the hell would I care?"
Well, you don't have to be inundated
with hundreds of Scorpio
memes on social media
to know that astrology has gotten big.
In 2018, Americans spent $2.2 billion
on mystical services, i.e. astrology,
tarot and psychic readings.
Meanwhile, astrology apps raked in a chill
$40 million the following year.
Skeptics of astrology,
like astronomer Carl Sagan,
have fairly pointed out the
lack of scientific evidence
supporting the practice.
- How could the rising of Mars
at the moment of my birth
affect me, then or now?
- But that, to us, is probably
the least interesting thing
about this phenomenon.
Whether astrology works
isn't the question.
The question is, in our
science and tech-happy era,
what makes the spiritual
craft of astrology
so endlessly compelling to so many people?
Let's dip a toe into the mystical
in this Wisecrack Edition
on How Astrology Captivated
the Modern World.
But first, I wanna tell you
about our sponsor for
today's video, SelfDecode.
Unlike letting the stars
tell you who you are,
SelfDecode is a service
that uses actual science
to help you get insights about your genes
and thus your health.
Through a combination of
AI and machine learning,
SelfDecode analyzes your genome
to make health recommendations
that are tailored to your unique needs.
The process was really straightforward.
I spit in a tube and mailed it to them
in a prepaid envelope.
Gross, I know, but simple.
After about six weeks, my
wellness reports arrived.
And while they confirmed a lot
of things I already expected,
I was surprised at just how much my genes
could tell me about my
health and my personality.
Case in point.
Apparently, I have so many genes
associated with anxiety
that of all the people SelfDecode tested,
I'm at the top 97 percentile.
That's a solid A.
This will come as no surprise
to anyone who knows me in real life.
But I didn't expect my high-key
fear of basically everything
to show up in my genes
as strongly as it did.
I was also really intrigued to find out
that I have a lot of genes
that are associated with
high coffee consumption
and the gene that's associated
with drinking less water,
which might explain this.
What I liked about SelfDecode
is that along with your health reports,
the company gives you actionable insights
on how to improve your health
based on what works for your genes.
So, for example, apparently
people with my variant
of the BDNF gene see a lot of improvement
in anxiety symptoms with exercise.
So maybe I'll start going
for a run or hit the gym
the morning before I
have to get on a podcast.
SelfDecode's wellness reports
are full of useful recommendations
for diet and lifestyle changes,
and even on potentially
helpful supplements
that can help you optimize
your personal health.
That said, SelfDecode is
not a diagnostic tool,
but it does give you some
genuinely useful insights
that can help you make wiser decisions
when it comes to taking care of yourself.
If you're ready to learn about your genome
and how to make the most of it,
check out the link in the description.
At checkout, use the code WISECRACK
to get 25% off your SelfDecode order.
And now, back to the show.
Now, the human impulse to find meaning
in the stars is nothing new.
Ancient Babylonians were
reading the night sky
back in the 2nd century BCE.
In ancient Greece,
astrology developed in
tandem with astronomy
and was treated with respect
by the likes of Ptolemy and Plato.
Throughout history,
kings would use court astrologers
to help them make important decisions
like who to invade or what
flavor ice cream to eat.
In the 12th century,
astrology became heavily tied to medicine,
and the job title physician
astrologer was a real thing.
Astrology was even taught at
universities across Europe
until the late 17th century!
But around then, The Age of Enlightenment,
coupled with propaganda
and political pressure,
put a dent in astrology's credibility.
For a couple hundred years,
it was relegated to a fringe
interest of freaky weirdos.
For a long time, in many places,
it was even illegal to predict futures.
The spiritualist movement of
the mid-to-late 19th century
would revive the ancient craft somewhat,
but it would never be as well-respected.
Fast forward to the swinging '60s,
and baby boomers zealously
embraced astrology.
And to this day, it's remained a huge,
if hugely mocked, part of our culture.
But how did we get here?
What accounts for astrology's
enduring popularity?
You can largely thank
occult enthusiast Alan Leo,
a late 19th century New Ager
who super liked reading the stars.
But he had a big problem,
it was still illegal in England
to predict the future for money.
So, after going to court and
being fined for his lil' hobby,
he took his lawyer's advice
and stopped making predictions.
But what good was astrology
without predictions of death,
thunderstorms or unsightly
pimples on your wedding day?
Leo was about to figure it out.
See, he also believed
that the Age of Aquarius
was fast approaching.
This was going to be a blissful
era of raised consciousness
and humanity reaching its true potential.
He wanted to help everyone get ready
for this dope galactic spectacle,
specifically by achieving
better self-understanding.
Importantly, Leo believed
that character is destiny.
That meant astrology should help people
better understand their
character and temperament,
rather than predicting external
happenings like car crashes.
And here's the major plus,
describing someone's personality
is not technically telling the future,
thus it was not illegal.
Now, quick sidebar,
you know your sun sign?
That's not your whole
astrological picture.
Professional astrologers take into account
the position of every single
planet in the solar system
when crafting a star chart.
But that shit is very complicated
and requires a lot of math and training.
Thus, it was super expensive
and pretty much exclusive
to the upper class.
This made astrology kind
of hard to popularize.
So Leo came up with the ultimate shortcut,
teach people their sun sign,
and draw conclusions about their character
based solely on that.
This bite-sized approach
to the craft proved massively popular.
Soon, newspapers would
start publishing horoscopes,
and life would never be the same
for any of you two-faced Geminis.
Just kidding!
But yeah, he basically made
abbreviated horoscopes a thing.
Though he couldn't have possibly predicted
the 21st century meme explosion
he was effectively setting in motion.
Leo's sun-sign-only approach
would largely define modern astrology.
Standardizing zodiac signs also,
helpfully, made astrology
marketable on a massive level
via cheap almanacs.
Conveniently, this was happening
just as the consumer capitalist economy
was entering full swing.
At the same time, Leo
would inspire astrologer
Dane Rudhyar to take this character stuff
a step further in the 1930s
by invoking a sparkly new
type of science: psychology!
Specifically by borrowing
from one Carl Jung.
Side note, turns out
Jung was a big ol' weirdo
who liked alchemy and astrology.
In fact, Jung liked astrology so much
that it's speculated
his zeal for the craft
was at least partially responsible
for his famous breakup
with mentor Sigmund Freud!
This makes sense because,
as writers Keiron Le Grace
and Safron Rossi explain
in their book Jung on Astrology,
"At root, both astrology
and Jungian psychology
might be seen as being engaged
with the critical task of
developing greater self-knowledge,
of bringing to awareness
the unconscious factors
underlying our life experience."
Rudhyar formally merged astrology
with Jungian psychology,
especially his notions about
the collective unconscious
and archetypes.
Thus, he created "psychological astrology"
and popularized the idea
of reading your horoscope
as a cheaper version of seeing a shrink.
Rest assured, not everybody was happy
about the mainstreaming of astrology.
In 1952, cultural critic and
notorious grump Theodor Adorno
wrote a semi-aggressive 78-page screed
critiquing sun-sign columns.
He declared that fans of astrology
were "persons who do not any longer feel
that they are the self-determining
subjects of their fate."
He studied Los Angeles Times horoscopes
and noted certain themes.
Specifically, that they seemed
to promote bourgeois values
like tact, hard work, and success,
while flattering people
about how intuitive they supposedly were.
He wondered how, in the
age of astrophysics,
anyone could possibly believe
that their personality was
affected by their date of birth.
That same question
continues to be posed today.
For her part, scholar Kirstine Munk argues
that two world wars, nuclear weapons,
and the environmental crisis
have all made science
seem a lot less sexy.
This then leads people to seek out
decidedly-unscientific
things like astrology.
But what if the popularity of astrology
in modern times isn't just explainable,
but was actually pretty inevitable?
Back in 1966, sociologist Jaques Maitre
argued that astrology is
actually a perfect fit
for modernity, and many have since agreed.
See, as scholar Marshall Berman explained,
rapid change is one of the
central tenets of modernity.
Whether it's the decreased
power of religious
and other social institutions,
or rapidly increasing globalization,
our world is in a constant state of flux.
As Munk explains, "The world
today seems more enchanted
than ever, but is also in certain ways
more dangerous and demanding.
We are constantly faced with
the challenge to make decisions
and to act in the world
without full knowledge
and without a privileged point of view."
Frequent job changes, cross-country moves,
divorces and so-on add far
more variables to everyday life
than our ancestors ever had.
Meanwhile, a decaying social fabric
leaves us all as lone agents,
trying to figure out how to behave.
This creates fraught situations
where we worry about
making the wrong choices,
about being the wrong kind of person.
As scholar Olav Hammer writes,
"In late modernity, we
construct who we really are
by engaging in self-reflexive speculation
and considering a variety of options."
That's where astrology comes
in for a lot of people:
as a mediating force
to help them make sure
they're not fucking up.
As Munk puts it, "To
use astrology is a way
to claim a home in the cosmos."
That's during a time when a lot of us
don't have that psychic
home anywhere else.
That's why astrology is
particularly attractive
to people in liminal situations,
like a breakup or job loss.
In a world full of choices,
the guidance of the stars,
no matter how unproven, can
feel centering for some.
Munk notes that astrology
both lets us feel "acted upon"
by forces larger than ourselves
while also helping folks
"to make a shift of perspective
and to reconstruct their worlds
in slightly different ways."
Reading your horoscope on
the internet, she explains,
can "magically create a
foreground and background"
for the "self-reflective
modern individual"
who might feel ungrounded
in their real life.
In this way, she believes its appeal
is largely about "agency and empowerment."
Perhaps it's no wonder, then,
that astrology has, in America,
traditionally attracted
marginalized groups.
Like women and people of color,
who are all too often
denied power in daily life.
Some scholars think
astrology even functions
as a powerful coping mechanism.
This all makes it somewhat
ironic that astrology
has become an important spiritual
outlet for so many people
precisely because it's so aptly adjusted
to modern capitalism and mass production.
But the popularity of astrology
is also reflective of the way
society now sees individuals.
Remember how old-school astrology
was all about big events like
wars and royal coronations.
Rather than about little old you
and your inexplicable romantic
affinity for mouth-breathers?
That's in large part because,
before the early modern era,
individualism wasn't all that important.
It was thought that every person
had a few basic core
characteristics in common.
But the concept of the unique individual
eventually caught on, with a little help
from Renaissance philosopher
Michel de Montaigne,
among others.
In our late modern times, the
pursuit of that authentic,
unique self has become paramount.
And astrology is one way of sussing out
and understanding your own
quirks and idiosyncrasies.
In the process, Hammer explains,
we've seen "decreasing
concern with cosmogonic myths
or social charters and
an increasing insistence
on personalized legends,
self-centered rituals
and the spiritual transformation
of each individual."
The individualization of religion,
of finding salvation in your own self,
is distinctly modern and
perfectly suited to astrology.
And this understandably coincides
with the overall reduction in power
of organized religions in our age.
Hammer writes that, these days,
"Not only is truth to be
found within each of us:
the very locus of
spirituality is our own self."
But what if your own self
is kind of discombobulated?
How can you make sense of your life?
Astrology can help with
that too, apparently.
As Hammer explains, astrology
facilitates something
called Narrativism,
which "conveys the idea
that we tell the stories of our lives,
stories that construct a temporal
unity for our identities,
and that link our specific life histories
with purported grand overarching themes."
In this way, Hammer writes,
it "offers a conceptual framework
for constructing a
narrative unity of life"
and "furnishes a narrative form
within which one's life
history can be understood."
Hammer even says these narratives
can function as
"therapeutic interventions."
Though please don't break
up with your therapist
just because you can
blame all your problems
on Mercury being in retrograde.
Linguist Charlotte Linde argues
that narrative is one of
the most powerful ways
of creating and maintaining
one's personal identity.
Narrativizing can also help
you establish causality
and coherency in your life story.
Didn't get asked to prom?
Blame pesky Venus.
Didn't get that promotion?
(beep) You, Mars!
Essentially, astrology
can help us explain away
the apparent randomness of human life.
And according to Linde,
it can do that regardless
of if we fully believe in it or not!
As Munk summarized,
"In such a disorderly world,
astrology offers a symbolic
and metaphorical system of imagining
within a frame of order."
Even if that order is, you know,
not at all scientifically proven
and pretty randomly concocted
by a few savvy 20th century
spiritual entrepreneurs.
But what do you guys think?
Is astrology distinctly modern,
or a lingering remnant
of ancient spirituality?
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out our podcasts.
Hit that Subscribe button
with the fury of a vengeful Capricorn,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching, peace.
(upbeat music)